bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue où nous allons bien sûr continuer de
parler de johnny hallyday johnny
hallyday et les politiques johnny
hallyday et les français peut-être pas
johnny hallyday l'artiste parce que
c'est pas notre spécialité encore que
nos invités ont sûrement des points de
vue à nous donner aussi là-dessus bon
soir lucile schmid
vous êtes co président de la fondation
verte européenne votre dernier livre la
france résiste-t-elle à l'écologie est
paru l'année dernière aux éditions du
bord de l'eau qu'on soir denis tillinac
dont son écrivain journaliste essayiste
votre dernier livre c'est l'âme français
si albin michel en 2016 nous en avoir
trouvé un autre elvis balade sudiste
vous connaissez très bien le dise pressé
et donc forcément aussi très bien johnny
hallyday bonsoir c'est en marchant
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste
scientifique chroniqueur à l'opinion
votre dernier livre les secrets de votre
cerveau est paru il ya quelques semaines
chez fayard et bonsoir yves thréard
qu'on ne présente plus éditorialistes et
avec leurs adjoints de la rédaction du
figaro animateur du toc et bien d'autres
choses dont on n'a pas le temps de
parler puisque ce soir évidemment le
héros c'est johnny hallyday je vous
propose de commencer par parler de ces
réactions des politiques est ce qu'elle
vous paraissent eux bienvenue est ce que
c'est une figure obligée pour fixer un
petit peu le cadre nous allons voir et
ses parents entre d'entrer en scène
manuel valls jack lang françois hollande
jean pierre raffarin et emmanuel macron
on a eu évidemment chacun de foule le
souligne jean d'ormesson est mort il ya
quelques heures aussi avec 48 heures à
peine la fête faut citer c'est johnny c
est une part de nous-mêmes d'une part de
la france qui tue par et il a il a
accompagné des présidents république des
sociétés comme s'ils allaient le sol se
dérobe sous nos pieds parce que johnny
et toute notre histoire toute une
histoire
ce sont des moments fabuleux de denezy
le spectacle fait c'est c'est toute
notre toute notre vie qui est heures etb
grohl est touchée et émue pour ça qu'il
était aimé parce que il y avait à la
fois
une familiale familiarité que l'on avait
avec johnny et il restait à bien des
égards un mystère mais ce mystère fait
partie de son talent dans les états de
fatigue
combien de fois je les ai vus avant un
spectacle de danse sentiment d'être
ailleurs
après un spectacle en étant quelque fois
épuisés mais pendant le spectacle
il se donne à tous et cette générosité
humaine cette générosité vital qu'il a
toujours exprimé et on a toujours trouvé
de la force en lui et cette générosité
fait qu'on lui a tout partenaire de tous
les milieux qui lui étaient fidèles qui
s'étaient beaucoup identifié à lui parce
qu'elle fait partie de ces héros
français vous avez j'ai souvent dit
qu'il fallait des héros dont qu'un pays
soit grand fait partie des héros
français johnny il était mais dans des
conditions très difficiles
abandonné par reconnu par son papa et il
avait construit une vie de courageux
responsable politique la font leur
travail ils sont à leur place je serais
laissé parler les français non c'est une
figure imposée et qui n'ont pas les
écrans et puis c'est plutôt les micros
qui vont vers eux sont obligés
s'exprimer celui qui dit je n'aime pas
de johnny ou johnny représente rien pour
moi on le croirait pas d'ailleurs on
dirait du mans pourquoi parce que
djoliba il a traversé j'avais dire les
siècles
il n'a pas traversé les siècles il a
traversé les disques à travers c'est
celui là mais nous aussi reprenne enfin
ça fait quand même 60 ans qui n'est sur
scène
enfin pas loin de 60 ans qu'il est sur
scène nécessairement tout le monde a
quelque chose de joli comme écrivait
alexis brézet cette nuit donc c'est
évident qu'ils sont obligés de ceux de
se prononcer et puis et puis ils ont le
droit pour certains d'entre eux de vrais
fans alors on écoutait raffarin jean
pierre raffarin il a toujours dit que il
connaissait très bien johnny là on va
laver trop vert avait chanté les
chansons de jeudi quant à manuel valls
se trouve que son épouse parce que
l'expert convient d'entendre il était à
new york manuel valls cette nuit il a
réagi depuis new york
il se trouve que anne gravoin son épouse
moi je les ai vus a joué dans un concert
de johnny à l'occasion de ses 70 ans au
sac de france donc ils sont tout à fait
légitimes me semble-t-il à s'exprimer
sur quelqu'un qui fait partie du
patrimoine national
c'est évident d'élite in acte si les
travées ou est ce que les politiques en
faux par un petit peu beaucoup comme ils
ont tendance à le faire sur tous les
sujets ils ont tendance à le faire tous
les sujets mais en l'occurrence c'est
légitime
bon c'est un c'est un peu une figure
imposée mais c'est bien quelque chose de
commun entre jean doe
et johnny c'est qu'il n'ya pas d'ennemis
comme comme à dives personne tout le
monde l'aimait bien gênés à l'idée
il incarnait bon on va dire que jean do
incarnent deux vers la version élitiste
de notre pays à la grandeur d'âme si
j'avais eu la version plus pop plus
populaires oui non pour une fois il ya
ne reprochons pas nos politiques ont
assez à leur reprocher leur l'occurrence
ajouté je pense que leur leur émotion et
sincère je l'éprouvé nous l'avons tous
éprouvé il a carnet quelque chose de
profond dans le lam populaire de ce
peuple depuis un prix de l'essence et
d'ailleurs on va pas chercher à vous
opposer là dessus vous êtes aussi
d'accord lucile schmid
c'est oui moi je suis d'accord sur le
fait que tout soit johnny hallyday
côtoyait déjà depuis très longtemps en
fait les politiques français c'est à
dire que on sait que il était
régulièrement dans l'élite et dans les
meetings de jacques chirac il a
accompagné nicolas sarkozy
il a déjeuné avec françois hollande
enfin d'une certaine manière et puis on
voyait dans l'intervention de jean
pierre raffarin une émotion réelle et
une proximité amicale
je crois que ça faisait partie entre
guillemets des people c'est à dire que
ça montre aussi combien les milieux
politiques
et puis la vie de johnny hallyday
d'abord je crois qu'ils les fascinait
d'une certaine manière les politiques
parce que ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron
qu'il a sûrement moins côtoyé était
aussi intéressant il a commencé à
raconter le récit d'un petit chose
français qui s'en est tiré d'une manière
remarquable est en quelque sorte par sa
volonté
je ne sais pas si c'était aussi simple
mais en tout cas le récit de la vie de
johnny hallyday visiblement peu fasciné
les français les politiques et comment
cela est en tout cas je suis pas sûr que
johnny hallyday savez très bien comment
fonctionnait la vème république mais il
ya quelque chose sur sa proximité avec
le politique il fascinait les politiques
et il était peut-être aussi fascinée par
ce débat politique par sa longévité est
sonné par sa popularité et son énergie
et sa popularité je la bête de scène
c'est aussi une bête de meetings on va
on va on va revenir sur ces sujets
stéphane marchand est ce que ce genre de
match c'est l'occasion aussi pour les
responsables politiques de tous bords de
montrer que qu'ils ont aussi un coeur
que ce sont pas juste des technocrates
efficace quand on entend emmanuel macron
qui sûrement vraiment ému d'ailleurs qui
parle de son de son
d'un homme qui n'a pas connu son papa on
est on est dans l'émotion légitime
on est dans le quasi pathos mais faire
de la politique c'est aussi artérielle
terre faire de la politique ça consiste
à nouer une relation aussi profonde
cocteau ci avec un électorat et il est
clair qu'il faut pas rater ce genre
d'occasions parce qu'avec la mort de
johnny une grande partie du pays est en
état de choc et les mots que prononce
les hommes politiques on s'en souviendra
on se souviendra de l'homme politique
qui aura été un peu froid aujourd'hui
qui n'aura pas été au diapason du pays
donc c'est important ce qu'ils disent
mais en même temps on voit bien les
échelons de génération par exemple les
mains de la crau ce sont des phrases
très ciselée bic ont été construites
on voit un peu par un service de
communication raffarin on voit une
émotion réelle il ainsi sur le fait
qu'il a été au contact physique de
johnny hallyday est la relation que les
français ont avec johnny hallyday
c'est une relation physique c'est une
relation c'était la puissance physique
incarner la vie
le don absolue de soi sur scène et donc
et donc c'est très important si c'est
très important c'est un moment politique
important aussi
ta maman politique parce que c'est aussi
ça le la fin de la gauche et de la
droite d'emmanuel macron 7 cet hommage
unanime c'est plutôt la réalité c'est
que les hommes politiques se rêverait en
johnny hallyday regardez le consensus
complet une relation total une fidélité
absolue malgré les erreurs malgré les
fautes malgré certaine médiocrité
c'est le rêve de tout homme politique
donc même si les cibles ans il a été
quand même il faut le dire plus proche
de la droite que de la gauche
vous avez cité sa proximité avec jacques
chirac avec lequel il avait la même
fibre ça c'est tony qui pourrait en
parler là même la même fibre populaire
cette façon toucher les gens kiki qui
existait aussi évidemment chirac
il était très amis ça il l'a jamais
cacher ni l'un ni l'autre d'ailleurs
avec nicolas sarkozy et il était plus
proche est alors quand même
alors c'est ça c'est ça aussi quelques
belges écuries on oublie de le dire
la fête de l'humanité ils ont tellement
bien préparé leur laisser au moins c'est
consommer séquence suivante oui mais il
est quand même si vous voulez son mode
de vie
c'est quand même l'argent aussi
puisqu'il a gagné beaucoup d'argent
c'est l'agglo en 2016 fait qu'il est
plutôt ses vrais proches voir s'il est
vraiment c'est vraiment un chanteur de
droite je reviens juste sûr sûr sûr sûr
cet hommage unanime
est-ce qu'il n'est pas un peu forcé par
exemple si jack lang est ce que jack
lang était vraiment afin de johnny
hallyday enfin ce qu'on pressent de c2c
de ses idées musicales on en n'est pas
complètement certain mais j'avoue que
j'extrapole un petit peu peut-être jack
lang il a tout le monde
jack lang aussi il s'efforce d'apprécier
tout c'est quand même on peut le lire on
peut critiquer jack lang je pense que
jack lang avec andré malraux et même à
droite c'est partager ça a été quand
même à ministre de la culture qui a mis
en valeur justement la musique populaire
la fête de la musique c'est jack lang
tout le monde peut jouer de la musique
jack lang et ayant clairement avec
l'unss un prince un arbitre des
élégances culturelle des années
mitterrand
mais c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
allait aussi dans la culture populaire
et même si ces mots sont peut-être un
peu forcé et puis il prépare et on peut
lui reconnaître une certaine une
certaine fidélité filiation par rapport
à ce qu'il a été combinées de l'anp
s'est très bien passé procès d'intention
alors je retire mes réticences sur la
plage l'authenticité de jack lang dans
son témoignage
oui mais pas ce que je voulais dire
c'est que cette question du consensus
qui est une question importante façon il
est mort donc il ya aussi le respect par
rapport à la mort mais il ya aussi une
autre chose c'est que il ya une forme
effectivement ne peut-être de faussetés
parfois du consensus je regardais ce qui
s'est passé autour du tweet d'alexis
corbières ce matin qui a osé dire la
somme misée voilà de la france dans
toute la france a soumises qui a osé dit
johnny est mort mais la politique
continue il ya eu une espèce de
d'indignations c'était juste pour réagir
par rapport à ce qu'a dit stéphane
marchand c'est à dire que je crois que
tout homme politique ne souhaitent pas
forcément le consensus a priori autour
de sa personne et donc la question du
débat d'idées elle continue je pense en
revanche johnny hallyday avait cette
espèce de force humaine d'énergie
incroyable qui au fond lui a attiré les
sympathies de la gauche et de la droite
et c'était authentique après le débat
d'idées politiques il doit continuer on
ne doit pas rester dans l'émotion
indéfiniment alors est donc quelque
chose que j'aime république incarnée oui
on est dans un moment où la voiture de
marne est ce que c'est une idée pas
carnet belle se fait d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron en racontant l'histoire fantasmée
de johnny hallyday ne veut pas laisser
quelque part transparaître un peu de sa
propre histoire enfin yaya il ya des
choses autour de la direction il ya des
noms si on regarde bien pour leur part
de son deuil a raison de dire que
c'était quelqu'un qui était mais aussi
par tout le monde
attention aussi aux questions dans
vraiment je dirais tu que la france
totalisait ne connaissait pas gendarme
et sociaux
c'était un inconnu si on sait bien sûr
si on s'intéresse à la france populaire
effectivement à la france populaire
c'est toute la france où il ya deux
personnes aujourd'hui qui peuvent
prétendre au statut de johnny y en a que
deux peut-être trois d'ailleurs c'est
zinédine zidane qui aimait droite-gauche
pas il n'y a pas de barrière il n'y a
pas de voie là chez les riches et peau
d'une femme chez les hommes c'est tout
le monde
johnny hallyday est peut-être peut-être
mais il a été plus controversée d'une
certaine façon michel platini aussi
voyez mais voilà c'est il y en a pas
beaucoup d'aidé genre de truc c'est le
divan d'autres mamans
collectif chère madame pour l'imaginaire
collectif les le sport est devenu
déterminant les parthénogenèse masculin
c'est à dire que je sais pas je sais pas
si c'est sûr que j'aurais aimé vous
citez annie famose brigitte bardot
peut-être aussi leon dont on disait les
politiques aiment tous johnny est ce que
johnny le leur rendait ben pas forcément
souvenez-vous de cette interview à
daniel rondeau s'est dit qu'en 1998 et
disait j'aime bien jacques chirac de
l'utilisation souvenir puisque lui aussi
aime bien jacques chirac jacques chirac
mais je suis comme tout le monde
déçu même si on oublie qu'il avait
hérité d'une france chancelante
je n'aime pas beaucoup ce qui se passe
en politique trop de corruption de tous
côtés et trop d'hommes politiques qui ne
rêve pas à la france mais qui rêvent
simplement d'être des stars qui a dit
que johnny hallyday n'était pas
intelligent
c'est vrai il était intelligent mais il
était aussi modeste parce que j'ai
retrouvé une phrase de lui disant je
regrette les bêtises que j'ai dit sur la
politique par maladresse cela m'a
renvoyé à ce que je suis un musicien qui
n'est pas armé pour parler de politique
donc c'était un homme modeste d'ailleurs
ils étaient treize ans 13 ans réserves
sur tous ces sujets on va là on va on va
le revoir je salue tous les internautes
qui qui nous rejoignent pour donner leur
hommage à johnny patrick nous chanterons
toujours tes chansons de johnny repose
en paix philippe je les ai vus lors de
son dernier concert au stade de france
et la chance d'être invité en voip un
grand moment
et puis eric qui nous dit la mort de
johnny hallyday c'est comme perdre une
couleur à notre drapeau français et ce
serait quelques couleurs le bleu le
blanc le rouge le blanc la paix
je répondrai comme le dessin de plantu
dans le monde cet après midi le bleu
le blu ray le rouge et crois pas c'est
en fait c'est comme si les couleurs
étaient moins cela tu en voilà
alors est-ce que johnny était un
chanteur politisé est-ce qu'ils étaient
de droite sont là on a parfois dit pour
nous aider à nous faire une idée je vous
propose de revoir une séquence des
politiques qui parlent de johnny nous
allons voir jacques chirac qui savoure
sarkozy qui chantent
raffarin qui mime et mâcon qui danse
[Applaudissements]
selon les spécialistes du comptage tous
plus experts les uns que les autres
il y avait cet après-midi sur
l'hippodrome de vincennes de 80 à 120
mille personnes il a l'habitude de dire
que je connais mieux les paroles de ses
chansons que lui et doivent être
vérifiées je veux partager autre chose
que l'amour dans son lit
et entendre la vue et plein les soupers
sous des cris je pense que ma prestation
de s'arrêter là fini pour moi catherine
voilà déjà quand il prend le micro à que
je t'aime que je t'aime c'est de
l'énergie qu'il donne johnny tonnes il
est généreux jean-pierre raffarin a même
chanté johnny dans les années 70 dans
les fêtes des jeunes giscardiens que je
t'aime
[Musique]
quatre jours
et denis tillinac qui ne pensaient pas
comme macron mais qui chantait comme
jeudi dans l'assemblée on passe vers
l'occurrence faire après nous laquelle
s'était clos soit chose merci on avait
dit que vous étiez un spécialiste hors
j'essaie de regarder qu'est ce qu'ils
pouvaient accréditer l'idée que johnny
était un chanteur de droite pour vous
les soumettre jacques chirac lui a remis
la légion d'honneur il a eu cette phrase
peut-être que c'était celle-là qui
regrettait d'ailleurs en dix ans on a
tous en nous quelque chose de jacques
chirac il était au fouquet's en 2007 le
soir de la deûle eu du succès de nicolas
sarkozy mais en même temps comme on dit
à l'elysée
il était allé à la fête de l'humanité il
était habile robert rue de georges
marchais vous évoquez d une géniale idée
un peu tardif rappelle que sa carrière
débute en 59 donné l'idée c'est un
enfant du gaullisme c'est la france un
peu alex la france qui se puisse le
blues c'est la france 2 qu'au passé la
porte de jacques anquetil faits atroces
de jalousie c'est la france des
chaussettes noires et des chats sauvages
ont travaillé avec les choses donc c'est
un enfant c'est un enfant naturel du
gaullisme c'est un début d'année a été
bon depuis le général de gaulle oui
c'est un gaulliste social à droite
gauche c'est un gaulliste il tarde
gaulliste la de la brandit de la haute
époque je dirais d'abord je trouve ça un
peu ridicule qu'on essaie de dire à
l'elysée qu'il est bouché qu'on essaie
de dire à droite jeu qu'il est de droite
je pense que la question c'est la levée
dès que de vous poser cette raison mais
vous assumez la non je parle moi j'ai
tendance à dire que d'ailleurs johnny
lui-même l'avait dit est ce que lui
demander son opinion politique et l
essentiel je crois pas après à mon sens
dans les valeurs qu'ils incarnaient la
réussite sociale
partir aux etats-unis je ne le sens pas
hyper à gauche mais j'ai le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui dans l'espèce de
gloubiboulga la confusion dans laquelle
on se trouve la question de la réussite
individuelle est tellement importante
qu'on peut décider qu'il est inclassable
donc moi moi j'aurais tendance à dire il
peut représenter un exemple très fort
pour des pour plusieurs générations
j'aurais aussi tendance à rappeler
puisque on me dit c'est un hommage
national et c'est que je suis pas sûr
que dans les jeunes générations
ceux qui ont 15 ans 20 ans 25 ans johnny
représente encore quelque chose comme ce
qui peut représenter un autre génération
donc il ya peut-être quelque chose
autour de ça mais si on paie vous parce
que dans la m on joue on joue des
chansons de johnny dans les écoles de
commerce au bal de fin d'année
on joue du sardou le connemara et des
chansons de johnny gabriel par exemple
françois et de claude françois donc non
non c'est encore extraordinaires sont
présents suis persuadé stéphane marchand
que lorsqu'il ya un bal une soirée une
partie un concert on joue du johnny
parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui nous
entraîne ya quelque chose d'ailleurs
s'entraînait denis tillinac
je suis pas sûr que connaître le
répertoire soit elle que j'ai faits
relève pour le coup de de ce qu'on aime
individuel
c'est le cas du collectif dans le jeu ni
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il ya
quelque chose qui fonctionne aujourd'hui
par rapport à l'ensemble de la société
française est en moi j'ai regardé moi
j'ai préparé l'émission pas avec des
citations mais j'ai regardé les sosies
de johnny parce que je me suis dit là il
ya quelque chose de très important sur
comment cette société se projette ou pas
et j'ai trouvé un nombre de sosie de
johnny incroyable comme claude françois
oui cloclo et johnny mais johnny et les
gens disent mais c'est moi le sale temps
à rêvasser aussi ce que si elle est
vraie politique je n'ai pas du tout la
preuve c'est que je vous invite à re
écouter ce qu'ils disent est le jour où
il est parti à son service militaire il
est parti à son service militaire il a
fait son service militaire du lycée par
alors que dans les années 60 et pas des
mines il y avait énormément de jeunes
qui est justement pas réparé rébellion
contre la société contre tous les fils
de bourgeois qui faisait warraq n'avait
pas et lui il est allé faire son sombre
et pourquoi il me dit je vais moi je
vais j'y vais parce que je veux faire
mon devoir national et j'espère que la
main d'ailleurs je vais pouvoir
entraîner des jeunes avec moi pour et
bien pour chanter pour qu'on fasse un
groupe et tout ça il était plutôt très
fier de défendre son à vous après qu'est
ce qu'il a fait ou vous l'avez vu il
était il anima
un congrès du rpr enfin une convention
de la berre il va à meeting de
l'humanité avec georges marchais pense
qu il va un petit peu il va un petit peu
partout en fait c'était un révolté quoi
et c'était un révolté je pense contre
son père surtout s'étaient révoltés de
la misère mais c'était pas un révolté
qui avait ide et ramsey qui avait
idéologie enfin quand même excusé mais
les premières images qu'on a vu là dans
le dans le meeting du rpr c'est pas
n'importe lequel
c'est le meeting de l'entré deux tours
de 1988 donc c'est chercher à séduire
contre françois mitterrand donc là quand
même si ça c'est pas prendre parti en
disant on a tous quelque chose en nous
de jacques chirac alors peut-être qu'il
aimait pas mitterrand bah oui l'impôt
sur la fortune à l'arrivée ils savaient
pas du passé parallèle avec un jean
d'ormesson c'est ce meeting était
désespérée ans avec mitterrand [ __ ]
une raclée à chirac ce qui a eu lieu il
ya trois types courage de monter ce
meeting à la murale de gaulle il à jean
d'ormesson et à johnny hallyday
et d'ailleurs je retire ce que j'ai dis
parce que j'ai fait une erreur c'est
avant le premier tour ce mais c'est
quand même ses amis c'est quand même si
dans la campagne votre immense et ses
engagements politiques ne lui ont jamais
rien qu'en finlande jamais il affaibli
ou coûté à sa carrière et je vous
rappelle quand même que certains qui ont
participé à la campagne de 2007 comme
faudel et bien se sont jamais relevés de
leurs soutiens politiques savent était
le cap faudel nicolas sarkozy en 1900 en
2007 a relevé et barbelivien aussi il
avait payé cher qui était un ami de york
en grande partie parce que effectivement
la popularité de johnny dépasse
complètement la différence gauche droite
moi je voudrais quand même dire à une
petite chose par rapport à cette espèce
de héros national c'est qu'en même temps
il choisit quand même un pseudonyme
c'est pas son vrai nom qui est ali daei
s'appelle johnny hallyday donc c'est un
héros national qui a quand même un non
sens mais ça je sais bien que c'est par
rapport à elle qu'un seul c'est très
intéressant six nations pour elvis a
passé toute la fascination 3,6 mais
c'est intéressant que la france qui
seraient projetés par rapport à
quelqu'un qui s'appelle johnny hallyday
qui chez nous fait du rock à la elvis et
qui est quelque part devient une espèce
de transcription national de d'elvis
presley
ça c'est quelque chose
dick rivers personne ne connaît je veux
connaître si les gens de ma génération
ne connaissent bien décrit bugs mais il
n'a pas traversé des générations à venir
aussi que je nie adapter son style au
mob magical successifs en ébène physique
la vue magnifique un extrêmement fort je
travaillais énormément il s'entourait
c'était beau c'était c'était c'était du
travail extraordinaire c'est johnny
c'est qu'effectivement c'était un
interprète en fait contrairement à
d'autres c'était quand même visiteurs
c'était un internet donc il interprétait
divinement bien beaucoup de musique et
eder et il a réussi à chaque fois à se
remettre en question et a connu un seul
trou d'air dans sa carrière de mémoire 1
je pense que c'est à la fin des années
soixante dix où la france comme la
plupart des pays occidentaux étaient
violemment versé vers un rock n roll
métallisé de fort et et john il a été un
peu perdue et johnny d'ailleurs moi je
me suis très bien j'étais jeune
journaliste ça sourire alors très précis
c'était en 1983
j'étais journaliste à bourg-en-bresse
concert de johnny hallyday à
bourg-en-bresse et ce concert a été
annulé faute faute de spectateurs
oui tout à fait c'était en 1983 où 84 et
il n'y avait pas assez de monde donc il
avait décidé d'annuler le concert qui
devait accueillir deux ou trois mille
personnes à l'époque on est là c'est
qu'on souvenir vous avez de l'utilité du
souvenir avec johnny hallyday
des souvenirs d'adolescence parce que
vraiment c'était
dir c'était un espèce de modèles mais je
me revois d'un moment on est con quand
on est ado j'étais avec une raquette de
tennis en guise de guitare depuis je me
trémousser dans ma chambre d'ado devant
la glace en imitant ses chansons
chantées souvenirs souvenirs trotter
mais deux problèmes
et puis surtout si un sous un beau
souvenir c'est grâce à sarkozy qui
m'invite dans une soirée privée pour
épandre où il y avait déjà née l'idée
son épouse et donc il ya quelques années
et il jaunit donc j'évoque cette période
moi je suis de mon temps donc mon johnny
c'est celui du début des années 60 ans
père d'un de ses neveux
j'ai même des chansons qui a
complètement oublié son épouse était
visible ce que sait même pas que ces
chansons existent et il y avait
barbelivien qui traînait dans cette
soirée qui traîne et était habitée est
appelée visiteurs et gentiment qu'est
née l'idée pour me faire plaisir à
chanter plusieurs des chansons de
l'époque que je préfère c'est à dire
l'époque aller jusqu'à le
les bras en croix dans la vallée de
l'oklahoma tant que le fusil way to
cette période moins que moi je le prends
comme ça
sarko il était tellement gentil et puis
ablakwa un modèle c est hélas il était
là parce qu'il aimait bien sarko tu sais
quand même bien ont communié dans la
même goût pour la musique on veut bien
qu'il soit drôle gauche de droite du
centre ou d'ailleurs s'en foutent
éperdument à ses souvenirs moi j'ai
aucun souvenir avec johnny hallyday
mais c'est que je vois bien que
progressivement il est devenue
consensuelle
alors qu'à mon avis dans les années 60
ou 70 c'était moins consensuel a déjà 17
les paroles je n'ai pas apprécié
l'émission est effectivement il y avait
le côté et 4 les chaises mauvais garçon
mais il traîne l'a très bien dit il va
faire son service militaire
et effectivement il fait des
déclarations tout parfaitement en phase
avec l'état major qui se marient à ces
jeunes donc donc avec sylvie vartan y
critique antoine qui a des cheveux longs
et des idées courtes
ils fument du tabac brun ça il paraît
que faire marqueur de droit puisque à
gauche on fait plutôt des cigares et
table avec elle donc donc déjà il fait
consensus en fait déjà
déjà il fait consensus à droite c'est à
dire que dans les années 60 70
moi je pensais à des amis un peu plus
âgés que moi qui m'ont dit que pour eux
johnny hallyday dans les années 60 70
c'était quelqu'un qui était de droite et
rappelons-nous de jean ferrat et c'est
donc qu'il ya quelque chose
ou peut-être qui faisait consensus
autour des jeunes et les parents mais
plutôt à droite est à mon sens il est
devenue consensuelle gauche-droite plus
tard je crois être avec les paroliers
peut-être lâche nathalie baye enfin je
n'en sais rien moi je pense qu'on
parlera de lowrie delà de la parenthèse
de cette relation avec nathalie baye
plutôt à gauche et à un moment là un
élément à mon avis assez important
moi je crois franchement qu en
politisant johnny hallyday entre rate
complètement l'essentiel il rappelé
personnage johnny hallyday c'est avant
que je ne connais pas personnellement
c'est avant tout un physique un don
physique incroyable son public
moi je ne connais comme mick jagger et
jacques brel qui me donnait cette même
impression phénoménal de de ce presque
se dissoudre sur scène pour moi excusez
moi qui le regarde et donc c'est cette
émotion là que je retiens la politique
lui s'en fichait complètement les
quelques erreurs qu'il a commises sont
des détails au vrai sens du terme
ce qui compte c'est ce lien incroyable
et izik et sa force c'est d'ajustement
d'avoir fait écrire à des gens aussi
bien de droite que de gauche
des paroles pour lui parce qu'il s'est
toujours entouré de gens qui est de plus
même un ya deux mois que ça écrit pour
lui
françoise sagan avec françoise sagan
était pour lui rondot il y avait
philippe labro a écrit pour lui ce sont
des gens il y en a de droiture et de
gauche et c'est ça tout le talent que
qu'avait johnny parce que en fait qu'ils
soient de droite ou de gauche ils se
mettaient tous au service d'une voix
qu'il savait inimitable imbattable bien
personne façon et un charisme fou et je
crois qu'on se battait même pour pour je
sais plus quel est le disque guillaume
hily pas si vieux que ça constitué
uniquement de chansons écrites par des
écrivains
c'était il ya dix ans à peu près 10 15
ans il a écrit ce disque c'est le disque
où il ya cinq ans d'ailleurs qui signent
un texte
et comme sa blessure qui lança va
entraîner pour mémoire et ça ça montre
que le le type de bail il aimait tout
quoi oui mais il aimait tous mais
seulement en france et donc moi je
m'interroge sur pourquoi est ce que
notre johnny national le visage pendant
1 110 millions de disques vendus dont
seulement 60 millions en france et la
belgique la suisse le québec
stéphane je pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet
sur la question de si il était aussi
charismatique s'il a une telle voie nous
on adore on adore ça
les nanos céline diamé spécial c'était
la concurrence elle dit sera conduit sur
la plateau bout le elvis faisait trop
d'ombré ni ailleurs campagne à cette
espèce de révolte d'adolescence même
cette invention d'usiné djorkaeff aux
états unis marlon brando de james bond
et puis elle vit ce qu'il a qui ne
focalisons na li se sont producteurs à
10 jours où je trouverai un blanc qui
chantait comme un noir je serai
milliards
ça a été une vie au milieu des années
cinquante cinq cas mortels ariane
période de révolte ou les pasteurs brûlé
son effigie enchères où il était vomi et
puis il a fait son service militaire
pour être un bon citoyen américain
les parents qui le lie son devenu dans
les années 70 et 80
ses supporters et on a une déclinaison
belvis par pays qui serait de chardin
d'angleterre bobby solo en italie peter
crouch en allemagne et donc ça pouvait
pas johnny hallyday cette seule soirée
où j'ai pu discuter avec lui il m'a dit
sans alice pressplay nous montrent moi
et les autres mes copains salir dieu
connu tant que nous étions rien du tout
elvis et son campus service militaire en
allemagne en plus c'est évident mais
vous le saviez pas ce que vous êtes des
initiés mais non moi je ne savais pas
non plus été au savoureux à succès
énorme aux états unis alors qu'il y
avait sinatra aux états unis très rigide
bien aussi l ancien correspondant du
figaro aux états unis mais il y avait un
succès quand même relative par rapport à
sinatra et dit bien fallu un succès
considérable royal mais parce qu'elle
n'avait pas concurrents elle a qu'a
regarder alors ce sont des visionnaires
ça il faut signaler quand même que jodie
essayer de faire une incursion je me
suis déjà en 1995 ou 16 jean-luc
d'acheter un jeune qui nous a précédés
station à las vegas y était à las vegas
a pas marché du tout il avait tellement
ça n'ait pas marché qui l'avait fait
venir par avion bas des fans de glee
français il pourra les meublés je dirais
le public sur place et c'était ça
prouvait qu'il avait du mal quand même
traversé les frontières en tous les cas
la francophonie on sait qu'on croit
d'ailleurs il a il a peu fait plusieurs
listes ou elvis lui a prêté ses
musiciens enregistrer les avaleurs de
lestrade hd2 on savait tous les
internautes qui nous envoient leurs
hommages
karine est une figure emblématique est
parti mais sa voie demeurera toujours
avec nos james qui nous dit dans une
histoire il y a un début et une fin ce
qui compte c'est qu'il écrit et claude
il était mon idole je limitais avec ma
première guitare reçu à la saint-nicolas
justement pourquoi est ce que les
français aimé autant johnny hallyday on
a commencé à y répondre
j'aimerais bien à votre avis sur le
sujet mais on va écouter d'abord ce
matin quelques témoignages d'anonymes
qui était à marnes-la-coquette devant le
domicile de géniale idée regardez son
départ pour moi c'est quelque chose
s'invite quoi il doit il remarquer
par sont enthousiasmés par le
le rôle fédérateur qui l'a eue auprès de
millions de gens par ses chansons c'est
ça qui est splendide
pour johnny tu me vois pas pleurer mais
je te jure de dans le choeur les salles
que en deux le curé brésil il m'a
toujours bercy j'ai toujours aimé cet
homme il était beau il était intelligent
il chantait il avait une carrure je fais
pas expliquer ce que je ressens
mais c'est vraiment très forts du trec'h
vous aussi vous avez des anecdotes sur
johnny dont j'ai une anecdote que m'a
raconté tenir bas salaires parce que
c'est un peu les coulisses de johnny
puis a acheté j'ai bon j'étais à ses
amis très habile un mec bien qui nous a
quitté quelques années et pierre
bachelet dans les années 90 avaient pour
coutume de faire les premières parties
de jean l idée et il m'a raconté qu'un
jour jena lee d'été malin de
complètement out
or hors service d'une certaine façon et
lui il s'apprêtait à aller sur scène des
listes demandait s'il allait pas obligé
de meubler toute la soirée et qui te
johnny va sur scène et qui te dit qu'ils
étaient quasiment bourran dans le
le backstage et il revient de sa
première partie est du jeudi chancelant
prend une gitane fume sagittale arrive
sur le scène et là c'était un homme
transformé il avait avait pu y avait
plus de deux maux de gorge le plus
complètement gonflés par une décharge
électrique
exactement et que c'était très très
impressionnant et il disait qu'il ait
cette faculté
parce que lille avait aussi doubles
cordes vocales c'est aussi pour ça
peut-être que les français et émettant
johnny hallyday c'est parce que il
représente 6,3 éternité de deux
jeunesses indestructible ouais malgré
tout les malgré toutes les difficultés
malgré tout les toutes les cris de tous
les excès et tous les abus parce que
c'était un c'était un géant une force de
la nature de l'énergie primal pure et en
même temps quelqu'un de très fragile on
connaissait son passé
on savait qu'il avait été abandonné par
son père ça a été une tragédie et ce
qu'il chantait était magnifique qu'est
ce qu'il disait était parfois très
touchant par exemple il avait dit un
jour le bonheur n'existe pas il n'ya que
la douleur continue à demander de 2,2 de
résumer sa vie et ça ce sont des choses
que l'écho les français ont intégré
comme une espèce d'émotion qu'ils ne
disent pas mais qui est là les
françaises n'ont pas ce que je voulais
dire c'est que à mon avis et il sait
transformer aussi en même temps que la
société française c'est à dire que je
crois que ce que les gens aiment c'est
la pérennité de johnny qui a pu
reconstruire 3 4 fois sa vie toujours
avec la même énergie est à mon avis le
met la même sincérité je pense que par
exemple la dernière fois quand il s'est
remarié
je pense que tout le monde s'est dit oh
ça va craquer au bout de 20 en deux ans
une femme trop jeune star est en fait un
peu malheureuse oui mais je pense qu'il
ya quelque chose autour de sa capacité à
revivre et avec une forme d'
enthousiasme qu'on n'a pas forcément
tous donc à une espèce de où je sais pas
où le fener phoenix à résidence là on
appelle ça la résilience et c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs quand même deux jours
avant sa mort finalement on nous disait
qu'il allait très bien je pense qu'elle
a une espèce d envie de croire qu'il
était immortel que qui est qui et c'est
un moment certainement particulière puis
moi je crois qu'il ya une projection sur
johnny comme disait stéphane marchand il
ya cette espèce de fragilité qu'on
ressent et en même temps ce talent
incroyable c'est à dire que dès qu'il
arrive sur scène il est transformé
chacun d'entre nous peut se dire qu'il
est comme ça non mais qu' il aimerait
que moi je crois que les gens le peuple
santé français santé que perçoit nos
élites comme cynique glacial et
arrogante et jean santé c'était un bon
gars quoi sert la main du coeur il était
sincère et pas une once de syracuse
sinon je pense quand même que
fondamentalement le mythe initial c'est
le mythe de l'éternelle jeunesse et la
jeunesse quand c'est quelque chose de
frais de jeu d'énigmes de printanier
cela franck 13 la france était jeune et
puissante elle été respectée dans l'été
respecter puis en mai on était heureux
de franchir pour brad et chanter pour
moi la vie va commencer on a
l'impression qu'ils nous ouvrait toutes
les portes bonheur elles se sont fermées
vers 67
après ça s'est gâté et ça continue mais
bon bon il nous a rejoint bonsoir
valentin sans surprise c'est un
raz-de-marée sur twitter un raz-de-marée
oui comme tu n'y as raz-de-marée de
tweets notamment plus de 140 mille
tweets avec le hashtag johnny hallyday
sur la journée c'est plus du double par
rapport à ce matin comme nous le montre
ce graphique absolument parlant
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le sujet qui
envahi twitter donc à valence de tweets
et parmi cette fuite quand on posait la
question pourquoi les français aiment
tiltant johnny hallyday non seulement
pour toutes les raisons que vous venez
tous d'aborder ici mais pour plein
d'autres notamment pour cette raison que
nous dit camille sur twitter parce qu'on
a tous un parent qui le mettait à fond
dans la maison on a tous grandi avec lui
ou encore cet autre internaute qui a
carrément mis la photo de johnny
hallyday en photo de profil avec écrit
repose en paix dessus parce qu'on a
grandi avec lui nous avons tous des
souvenirs avec ses chansons
nous avons également cet internaute sur
twitter qui nous précise parce qu'ils
chantaient et parler pour et à tout le
monde johnny hallyday était un artiste
qui rassemblait un exploit dans notre
nation aujourd'hui si profondément
divisé les internautes du figaro et sont
également attristé donc du coup par
cette nouvelle honneur à ceux vivant
parmi les vivants icône d'un champ d'une
langue d'un souffle d'un peuple
après piaf il faudra sans doute
longtemps à attendre avant de retrouver
une telle incarnation encore un autre un
interview du figaro deux piliers de la
france qui sont partis hier vont
d'ormesson pour la littérature est
aujourd'hui johnny pour la musique juste
avant les fêtes comme c'est triste
l'un vivait pour l'écriture l'autre
incarner la chanson française et on va
revenir effectivement oui autant pour
moi en fait à vrai dire il n'ya pas du
coup que les internautes qui réalise
mais également les lieux dans lesquels
ces produits johnny hallyday en
l'occurrence le compte twitter de
l'accord hôtel arena avec cette photo
souvenir de son premier passage chez eux
en 1987 le compte twitter de la tour
eiffel également à tweeté pour rendre
hommage à johnny hallyday
j'aurai toujours quelque chose en moi de
johnny hallyday la gendarmerie nationale
également rend hommage
quand johnny hallyday était le soldat
smet ou encore emmaüs france tu as une
responsabilité importante par ta
profession par la notoriété
il faut que ça serve à un monde qui est
malade disait l'abbé pierre à johnny
hallyday
j'en passe évidemment il y avait les
clubs de foot ou encore l'armée de l'air
énormément de réactions aujourd'hui sur
twitter
y compris d'ailleurs de l'église
catholique le cardinal barbarin qui
avait succédé à johnny hallyday à
l'hôpital de fort de france
l'aumônier spectacle qui organise une
veillée de prière à saint roch à paris à
un mot de commentaires sur ses sursis
tweet il ne vous surprennent pas mais
quand même
même si on s'y attendait nous autres
journalistes a fait tout à fait quand
même des mois qu'on s'est dit ça va être
énorme mais on est quand même surpris
non oui bah on est surpris oui mais on
s'attendait à ce qu'il y ait ça ceux ci
voulaient encore une fois je crois qu'il
ya pas une autre personnalité qui peut
dégager un pareil pari tendresse
finalement parce que c'est le tendresse
que la france dégage aujourd'hui 1
c'est exactement ça c'est on aime
beaucoup un peu mais il c'est quelqu'un
qui nous attendrit c'est comme stéphane
lundi ses origines son comportement qui
a toujours été quand même même si
c'était un type de boîte de nuit
d'ailleurs est ce intéressant quand il
dit il raconte ses bois de 8,6 il a peur
de la nuit dans le lit thériault qu'il
accorde à daniel rondeau chez nos
confrères du monde à la fin des années
90 il dit j'avais peur de la nuit j'ai
peur de la nuit ici j'ai peur de la nuit
va pour pas pour pour surmonter sa peur
je vais en boîte de nuit parce
qu'évidemment il y avait les moyens et
puis quand il aller en boîte de nuit il
emmenait tous ses copains jean reno tout
le monde y allait il servait tout le
monde il dit je détestais la musique qui
passait parce que pour moi c'était elle
était inaudible je déteste danser je
déteste danser mais j'étais là pour tuer
le temps finalement pour surmonter cette
angoisse que j'avais de la nuit bon il
ya une tendresse pour ce pour cet homme
qui comme vous l'avait bien dit aussi a
su rebondir à chaque fois finalement
aussi bien dans sa vie privée
ce que ça apparaît rien mais d'avec
laeticia ça fait 20 ans qu'il était
marié qui est ici avait eu deux enfants
dans lesquelles il a adopté deux enfants
avec elle il a il a su passer les modes
il a donc il ya quelque chose et il
l'aura semble finalement moi je passe
mal il ya un truc aussi dont on n'a pas
du tout parlé parce qu'au fond on est
complètement subjugué par le côté
donneur à l'ailé
oui mais aussi parce que vous racontez
votre espèce de passion pour johnny
hallyday
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui a été un
acteur au cinéma qui a faim moi ce que
je trouve c'est qu'il a pris des risques
je trouve que par exemple quand il a
rencontré bon moi je suis très sensible
à l'autre avec nathalie baye s'étend des
raisons évidentes mais enfin moi j'ai
regardé un petit peu des extraits de
films
je trouve que c'était plutôt un bon
acteur donc c'est quelqu'un qui s'est
pas contenté d'être un interprète
d'ailleurs bon acteur quand vous voyez
sur scène on voit que c'est un très bon
acteur c'est à dire quelque chose aux
six mois c'est le truc qui me fascine
presque le plus et je pense que c'est ça
qui fascine les politiques c'est cette
espèce de capacité au fond a créé un
engouement qu'ils essaient désespérément
de créer qui n'arrive pas à créer donc
il ya tout ça qui est à mon avis assez
extraordinaire et puis moi je me
demandais quand même une chose c'est que
cette espèce de bouffées d'émotion l'
énorme qui a aujourd'hui je me demande
si elle va durer je me demande ce qu'il
va se passer dans la durée par rapport à
ça parce que non mais c'est important
c'est important parce que on est quand
même dans un moment une société
extrêmement émotionnelles ou quelque
part de l'émotion a presque trop fort
tout de suite et ensuite est-ce qu alger
au vert voilà je me foutais menez vous
la victoire de la france sur la coupe du
monde en 1998
ça a duré le temps de quelques jours oui
enfin on s'en souvient quand même je la
perception j'ai l'impression qui a pas
eu une émotion pareil me semble-t-il
depuis la mort de de gaulle en novembre
69 70 excusez-moi j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya pas une émotion au mas je pense
qu'elle est populaire en france avec une
émotion qui ne s'exprime pas c'est ce
qui est là depuis très longtemps on le
dit depuis 1h l'émotion avec johnny
hallyday elle existe depuis 50 ans et
donc elle va continuer à mon avis
intacte aujourd'hui c'est une explosion
c'est une expression c'est tout ce qui
change en écoutant sa musique
l'émotion allez sûrement palpable aussi
à marnes-la-coquette devant le domicile
de johnny hallyday et de sa famille on
nous allons rejoindre tout de suite
jérémy ponthieu oui jérémie vous êtes là
on me dit que brigitte macron l'épousé
du président de la république serait
peut-être en route ou même déjà présente
à marnes-la-coquette est-ce que vous
avez cette information alors pour
l'instant effectivement je n'ai pas
cette information j'observe de moi même
je ne vois pas encore de
de la présence de brigitte vaincrons ici
alors il peut être qu'il est possible
qu'elle puisse arriver dans les minutes
qui arrive c'est pas impossible
ce qui est sûr en tout cas c'est que
madame lagon qui lui est en visite en
algérie actuellement expliqué qu'il
rendrait hommage à johnny hallyday quand
on ne sait pas exactement et et que la
journée en revanche chômage deuil
national en tout cas on n'a pas encore
toutes les informations les informations
peuvent arriver
est ce que je peux vous dire en tout cas
ici c'est que les que les fans
continuent d'entonner johnny hallyday
les chansons on en a croisé plusieurs
certains viennent de loin voilà ça c'est
ce que je peux vous dire pour l'instant
le flux d'aidé des admirateurs ne
faiblit pas depuis ce matin bien que le
soir soit tombé et qu'il fait froid
vous m'avez dit oui je vous disais que
le fleuve le flux des admirateurs ne
faiblit pas malgré leur qui avance et le
froid qui probablement monte alors
effectivement le froid vous le voyez de
ma bouche la vue s'échappe et non le les
fans ne faiblissent pas y en a même
certains qui sont venues des chansons à
la main des textes à la main pour
pouvoir chanter un maximum du répertoire
de johnny on en voit certains arrivé
d'ailleurs de plus loin puisque
forcément il faut un certain temps pour
arriver jusqu'ici donc l'enthousiasmé ne
faiblit pas auprès d'e.on va dire tu es
passionné ici et puis il ya toujours des
gens qui viennent aussi voir qu'ils sont
pas forcément connaisseur de toutes les
musiques qui viennent un peu voir ce qui
se passe donc là on a un peu le même
nombre de personnes ici à
marnes-la-coquette merci beaucoup je
répondrai en direct depuis marne la
coquette on vous retrouve évidemment
dans cette journée spéciale consacrée à
johnny on l'a dit à quelques minutes il
ya eu la mort de johnny hallyday il ya
aussi un homme qu'on aimait infiniment
au figaro qui vient de mourir qui était
jean d'ormesson alors de registres très
différents mais disait denis tillinac
quand même d'aider des points communs
entre entre ces deux hommes
lucile schmid moi ce qui m'a frappé
quand denis tillinac a commencé à en
parler c'est qu'il l'appelait jandaud
avec une espèce de 2,2
je sais pas d'amitié de complicité
d'affection et que moi je ne ressens pas
mais je me suis dit là au fond jean donc
j'aurais pu l'appeler comme ça parce
qu'il y avait une espèce de d'empathie
chez jean d'ormesson qui passaient y
compris pour des gens qui ne l'avait
jamais côtoyé donc moi mon la différence
par rapport à la différence par rapport
à ce qu'on vient de dire sur johnny
hallyday selon moi j'écris j'aime
l'écriture et je sais que c'est
difficile d'écrire donc ce qui me sera
pêche et jean d'ormesson c'était cette
capacité de communication et de parler
de l'écriture et au fond de rendre
compréhensible à tout le monde
la profondeur aurait adoré vraiment
puisqu'on l'a dit ça a été beaucoup
d'hier jean d'ormesson qui était quand
même un artiste de la conversation on
aurait adoré avoir une conversation
green hallyday jean d'ormesson parce que
j'ai des idées on sait que les mots
avaient du mal quand même à sortir
c'était pas un homme du verbe
c'était un homme de la voix et ce qui
aurait été extraordinaire c'est que jean
d'ormesson je suis persuadé aurait pu
faire sortir à
j'ai réalisé beaucoup de choses beaucoup
d'émotion ils auraient pu les traduit il
aurait sans doute été ça a été génial à
une conversation entre les deux mois
j'aurais préféré que nicolas sarkozy par
exemple soit capable aussi bien de
parler de tout l'écrivain jean
d'ormesson que de johnny hallyday parce
que je trouve tout à l'heure je regarde
coûts sont d'ailleurs il de les jeux
déjà meilleur je trouve qu'il j'ai vu
qu'il avait dit dans le figaro mais je
trouve que ça aurait été intéressant là
dessus que on sache par exemple que
nicolas sarkozy dont on a beaucoup
contesté la relation la culture dont on
a beaucoup parlé de la culture je vous
rappelle le truc de la princesse de
clèves au fond qu'il irait la princesse
de clèves
moi je trouve que j'aurais aimé
davantage pour le coup une vraie
conversation nicolas sarkozy jean
d'ormesson elle a existé même voix la
justice toi mais attention très anciens
jeux mais moi je suis pas je suis pas
anciens combattants pascal pas vieille
non a lancé avec le figaro il ya
quelques années avait sorti la
collection des classiques de la
littérature française sous la tutelle et
éditeurs et le contrôle éditorial c'est
utiliser les frais face d'eux le
concours éditorial de jean d'ormesson et
que et bien nicolas sarkozy s'est remis
à relire tous ces classiques grâce
justement à cette collection que le
figaro avait sorti et il y avait un
volume qui sortait par semaine ils eux
il je me souviens très bien être allé
dans son bureau à l'époque je peux vous
dire qu'ils allaient tous dans son
bureau l'elysée et que le dernier de la
semaine étaient toujours sur son bureau
et qu'ils allaient y raconte cette
anecdote d'ailleurs dans un livre qui a
écrit franz olivier giesbert il ya dix
ans et il raconte que j'ai l'air se
moque un peu lui disant peut-être que
nicolas sarkozy a découvert la
littérature grâce et bien agents dans ce
contexte vous avez pu apercevoir mis en
avant première la couverture de ce qui
sera le figaro magazine de vendredi où
nous rendons bien sûr un hommage très
ému pourquoi le cacher un jour dans le
son qui a été pendant 16 ans chaque
semaine le chroniqueur du figaro
magazine avec cette fameuse chronique du
temps qui passe
ce matin la ministre de la culture
françoise nyssen rend des hommages sur
europe 1
à ses deux idoles parce qu'après tout
jean d'ormesson aussi était une idole
pour beaucoup et elle les associer dans
un même hommage regarder pour jean
d'ormesson d'ormesson de deux voix deux
personnalités fortes comme ça qu'ils
s'éteignent qui se rejoignent qui nous
ont profondément marqué par par ce goût
du partage avec les autres
ce goût des mots les uns sont sur la
feuille de papier les l'autre chanter i
mérite vraiment que on voit avec leur
famille que l'on faire les associer dans
un même hommage du pays ça aurait un
sens où ce serait article je pense que
ça serait ça serait pas bien pour eux
pour chacun d'eux parce que il incarne
il pourrait pas chacun prendre la plaine
du mont voilà c'est normal il ya on sait
maintenant
guillaume je crois qu'il ya d'hommage
national pour jean d'ormesson qui va
être prononcé dans la cour des invalides
eux vendredi matin et on est en attente
de savoir ce qui va se passer projet
hallyday la rumeur court qu'il pourrait
même y avoir des obsèques nationales
pasquale mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
y aura un hommage national au minimum
pour l'idole des jeunes et on vous
montre aussi le hors série du figaro
magazine qui est qui est en kiosque
depuis quelques heures consacrée à
johnny hallyday
lefigaro.fr a posé la question
aujourd'hui aux internautes quelle est
votre chanson préférée de johnny
hallyday vous allez voir la liste qui va
s'afficher sur votre écran j'ai envie de
poser la même question à nos à nos
quatre invités lucile vous avez une une
chanson préférée de johnny est ce
qu'elle est dans cette liste oui tout à
fait
j'aime beaucoup laura et j'ai le droit
d'avoir un deuxième choix
oui vous avez tous les droits ici j'aime
beaucoup quelque chose de tennessee donc
c'est un peu le même registre
stéphane marchand moi la chanson que je
préfère c'est celle dans laquelle il ya
la parole j'ai oublié de vivre mais je
ne connais pas le titre de la chanson
voilà j'espère que les abreuver on
pourrait vous la chanter mais yves moi
c'est celle que je préfère c'est quand
il était justement un peu dans le creux
de la vague c'est jolie sarah je trouve
s'imaginait il fit que jenson la
deuxième que j'aime bien c'est diego qui
a été écrite par michel berger et la
troisième c'est parce que c'est lui qui
l'a écrit trois que je t'aime puisque
c'est la seule chanson je crois que jen
l idée est écrit t il le racontait je
crois que il y avait tué
beaucoup sur le texte parce que c'était
pas son truc décrire le résultat est là
et il répond en réponse à stéphane
marchand en régie ou on sait tous on me
dit que c'est aussi le titre de la
chanson est obligé de vivre par denis
dont j'aime beaucoup ce souvenir
souvenir c'est mon premier microsillon
mais je crois que sa plus belle chanson
c'est retiens la nuit et j'ai une
tendresse pour bien trop timide qui est
un peu moins connus merci à tous les
quatre d'avoir évoqué notre cher johnny
hallyday je vous propose évidemment de
terminée en chansons avec une sélection
de quelques unes des plus belles
chansons de johnny hallyday sur
différentes époques
écoutez merci
jusque là
tiens
[Musique]
le monde
c
[Musique]
il faut encore
de grands
mieux le jour
levrat
avi
les gens m'appellent l'idole des jeunes
eux
ils l'ont m
qui m'ont dit
bézy le simple pas
le vrai
[Musique]
tout seul
les
je pense à toi
tong
[Musique]
qui lit de riz
la voie aux
[Musique]
à deux mois
noir c'est noir
elia
dès ce soir
regus
oui
jamais rendu
g
et
[Musique]
des
à trop
ces choses et
[Musique]
et les désirs
3 met le feu à la place des arts on
n'est jamais des adieux rire que tu es
heureux voire qu'ils croient comme à la
tête
au sommet
j'y crois comme un enfant comme on peut
croire aux yeux ni toi matap ou à tes
bras qui me gêne pas
l'histoire
ferrante des autres
besoin d'y croire encore
on a tous quelque chose en nous de
tennessee volonté de prolonger la nuit
c'est désir fou de vivre une autre vie
un rêve en nous avec ses mots à lui
qu'elle touche aux de t d si mariah
carey
papa
cette année
[Musique]
avec sursis
on cherche et sutton
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce
l'oral
[Musique]
le temps passait me remplit de toi
je n'avais besoin de personne
exempt de place pour toi
[Musique]
bon
moi
savais tu sors
[Musique]
les
bien que
raté
[Musique]
c'est
st
papa
le salon
adjectif
[Musique]
saleh
le message
allez
[Musique]
bientôt
on sait
c'est là
les jeunes
le mali
comme d'autres
le nom
mairie